christine villemin est ce soir en
liberté sous contrôle judiciaire certes
elle reste toujours inculpé dans la
sphère du meurtre de son propre fils
grégory mais elle est sortie de prison
où elle avait fait où elle avait été
mise par michel lambert le juge
d'instruction
cette libération est elle un désaveu de
l'action du juge
une remise en question de la culpabilité
de l'inculpé ou encore une mesure
ménageant la santé de cette femme qui
est enceinte je vous le rappelle sur
place notre envoyé spécial marcel libre
après 11 jours de détention et cinq
jours de grève de la faim
cette femme enceinte de six mois qui a
fêté en prison 125e anniversaire a donc
tenu tête au juge lambert qui fait peser
sur elle depuis le 5 juillet la plus
terrible des accusations l'assassinât de
son enfant c'est à 16h05 cet après midi
que la décision de la chambre
d'accusation de la cour d'appel de nancy
était rendu public par m gare aux
avocats de la défense et permettre aux
lombards avocats de la partie civile
christine villemin est libre l'injuste
incarcération a cessé
les défenseurs ont été entendus après
une étude approfondie du dossier
cinq heures de débats et 24 heures de
délibéré les trois hauts magistrats de
la cour d'appel de nancy on sanctionner
la décision du juge d'instruction
nous n'avons pas à commenter la mise en
liberté sous contrôle judiciaire à
laquelle au nom de la famille villemin
nous nous étions pas opposé à partir
d'aujourd'hui pour la partie civile la
faire comme ans et mesure qui permet au
juge lambert de poursuivre son
instruction mais qui ressemble fort
un rappel à l'ordre à son égard pour
traîner à coup sûr que si mme villemin
devant les assises
il faudrait autre chose que ce dossier
construit sur des incertitudes et des
accusations sans preuve